good morning believe nation if you are
on the fence as to whether you should
start a new business or a new idea or
not I'm going to share with you an
inspiring clip from Sir Richard Branson
that I think will help I think a lot of
people do not have the courage to try to
start a business and all I was saying
when I've written a book called screw it
just do it and it basically is trying to
say to people just give it a try and
actually sometimes a very very small
amount of money is all that's needed to
start a company I mean they my mother
found a bracelet on the street and she
handed into the police station and they
and after three months the police there
to sell it and you know the the couple
of hundred dollars was really critical
at a critical time in the development of
our business so it's always safe just to
give it give it again
and good luck on that one so my quick
take on this is it's so easy to convince
yourself of all the reasons why your
ideas not gonna work out right you tell
yourself you don't the experience you've
never done this before you don't have
the money you know you don't have the
contacts the connections you've never
done this right you don't the education
you tell yourself all the reasons why
it's not gonna work out and and those
reasons are true right those are real
legitimate fears that you have as to why
not the start of business what you have
to do as an entrepreneur is not big not
get weighed down by all the negatives
all the holes in your plans but find
solutions look to the positive look at
why you're doing this look at why this
is important in your life and I think
most importantly not live and regret
right not wonder what would have
happened right when you're 7 and you're
looking back in your life and you wish
you had started your business but you
realize you were too afraid to do it so
this is something that you love this is
something that's a passion of yours this
is something that you know you don't
know how it's gonna work out but you
feel like you're gonna regret this if
you don't then stop thinking with your
head start using your heart and maybe
just take the approach of screw it let's
do it thank you guys for watching my
question of the day for you today is
I want to know the moment you decided to
launch your business what happened what
was the moment where you you embrace the
fear you pass by and you said you know
what there's all these reasons why it's
not going to work but I'm just gonna do
it any way I want you to describe that
moment for me leave in the comments
below I'm gonna join in the discussion
and I think it'll help inspire other
entrepreneurs who are struggling with
that decision as well thank you guys so
much for watching if you want to see
more videos don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and the newsletter and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of entrepreneurship to
kickstart your day
thank you for watching and continue to
believe and I'll see you soon